So I think this part of the course is always
a part I have difficulty with, because the
conceptual transformation is very, very large.
Because so far we’ve been talking about,
I would say, biological and evolutionary realities,
in a sense.
And we’ve been doing that in a relatively
standard manner.
I mean, there are elements of Piagetian theory
that run through it, there are elements of
cybernetic theory, there are elements of neurobiology
and neuropsychology.
And none of it, I would say in some sense,
is radically outside the way these sorts of
problems might be discussed in a typical scientific
or social scientific manner.
Except for maybe the fact that we’ve drawn
an explicit distinction between the world
as a place of things and the world as a place
of action.
Now there are consequences to the idea that
the world is a place of action that start
to become more radical at this point.
But drawing the relationship between what
I’ve already talked to you about and the
narrative domains that we’re going to explore
now, requires a… like a radical shift in
conceptual focus.
And so, the way I’m going to handle that
is by hitting it from ten or eleven different
directions, and building up a pattern.
You know, if you listen to a complex piece
of music, or at least this is my experience
with complex music, is sometimes, the first
time I hear it, I don’t really like it,
and I think I also don’t understand it.
I actually can’t hear it.
You know, maybe a musical genius could hear
the whole thing instantly.
You know, they say Franz Liszt could sight-read
anything on the piano first try.
So, you know, some people are so intelligent
musically that it’s incomprehensible, and
I’m sure they hear things just fine the
first time they hear them.
But then what happens for me is that if I
listen to it a couple more times or pieces
or chunks of it, they start to fall into place
that I can follow, and, you know, I can see
the beauty sort of shine through those.
And then eventually, the whole thing links
together, and then I can listen to it, especially
if it’s a complex piece of music, many,
many, many times.
And the more complex, and probably the better,
the piece of music, the more I can listen
to it.
But if I listen to it enough, at some point
then I’ve had enough of it, and it’s all
a very strange phenomenon.
Because one of the things you might ask yourself
is, what exactly are you learning while you’re
doing that?
You know, it seems like you want the music
to be just exactly the right amount of predictable
and unpredictable.
If it’s too unpredictable then you can’t
understand it and if it’s too predictable
it’s boring, and so it’s just like a conversation
that way.
It’s actually just like life as well!
You know, because you want things to be predictable
and stable, and you want things to be unpredictable
and interesting, and the degree to which you
want each of those is going to depend on the
time and the context and also on your own
intelligence and temperament.
Now, I’m going to tell you a bunch of stories
and give you a number of pieces of information,
and hopefully they’ll click together.
Now I think the reason this information has
always been transmitted in story and image
form is because it’s very, very difficult
to transform it into articulated, like into
fully articulated explanation.
It isn’t really how it works.
You know, we’re not really accustomed to
thinking about the idea that there are certain
forms of information (that are valid forms
of information) that can’t be transmitted
verbally.
But of course, if you think about it, we all
understand this deeply.
Well, I can give you a bunch of examples.
The first example is that when you speak,
not only do you speak in words and phrases
and sentences and paragraphs, but you also
speak melodically.
And in fact, part of the reason that you can
understand melodies and that they make sense
to you is that what artists have done is separated
the melodic elements of speech from the semantic
element, and then played with the melodic
element.
And the melodic element tends to carry a lot
of emotion and intent.
And so, if you’re listening to someone speak,
you can tell when they’re being ironic,
you know, because they raise an eyebrow, and
their voice changes slightly, even though
they might be using, in fact they are using,
exactly the same words.
And in fact someone who’s very good at being
witty or ironic will set the situation up
so that you can barely tell that they’re
joking, and the better they are at that, the
tinier the hint they give you that you can
still catch on to, the funnier the situation
is.
So we know that information can be transmitted
through non-verbal channels.
It even happens during speech.
And then, of course, we understand that music
presents to us an intimation of meaning that’s
very difficult to fully grasp.
And music for me has always been an ineffable
phenomenon in some sense because it carries
the intimation of meaning in a manner that
can’t be rationally dismissed, or that people
aren’t interested in rationally dismissing.
Even punk rock nihilists listen to punk rock
nihilistic music, and they find that meaningful
even though they don’t believe in meaning!
And you know, in some sense they’re victims
of their own rationality, because they do
believe in meaning (or else they wouldn’t
be listening to the music), but they can’t
understand how they could possibly believe
in it, so their rational mind has dispensed
with the idea.
And sometimes people dispense with the idea
of meaning, for lots of reasons.
Partly because it’s inevitable, in some
sense, with sufficient rationality, but also
because it’s always useful to look for the
underbelly of things, because it also justifies
not bearing any responsibility for your life.
And that’s fairly… that can be a very
desirable side-effect of the particular ideological
rational belief.
And then there’s dance, of course, and dance
is even more ineffable than music, although
it’s often paired with music, you know,
and it grips people.
If you see a remarkable dance performance,
well part of it is that you’re sort of thrilled
and excited about seeing just exactly what
the human form can do.
Perhaps, partly, because you’re human and
when you see someone extending a certain ability
far beyond the norm then it expands your sense
of what a human being is capable of, so there’s
that, there’s the pure skill element.
And then there’s the novelty element, because
often if you watch a particularly good dancer
there’s things they do that you haven’t
seen before that you didn’t know anyone
could do and that’s pretty fun.
And then often the dance is joined with the
music and the body is expressing what the
music means and even though you can’t tell
what the music means you can tell that the
dance is expressing it.
See I think what happens there is that music
represents the patterns of being.
It’s actually because people think of music
as a non-representational art, but I think
that’s wrong, I think it might be the most
representational art.
Being is made up of layers of patterns constantly
interacting, and hopefully in a relatively
harmonious way, and music demonstrates that,
mimics it in some sense, abstractly.
And then the dance is an abstract representation.
People adapt to the patterns of being and
the dancer adapts to the pattern of music,
and so it’s symbolic, it’s an embodied
display of the place of the person in the
cosmos.
And you could also make that case when you
see people dancing in pairs, because you could
dance alone or you could dance in pairs, and
that’s basically standard human adaptation.
And music is interesting too because one of
the things you’ll notice is that there’s
always music in a movie.
Almost always.
There’s the odd movie that doesn’t have
it but it’s quite marked when it’s absent,
you know.
The movie feels a lot more cold and clinical,
although it can work.
But we accept the idea that music can be used
to fill in the missing context in a movie
without even ever questioning it, right?
Like, it’s very strange if you think about
it, that you go to a movie that is doing…
at least part of its function is to portray
reality in a realistic way, but there’s
a soundtrack playing in the background all
the time.
You know it’s so useful and so appropriate
that you don’t notice how strange it is
that that’s okay.
So, my point is that we well, and then of
course you can talk about novels and plays
the same way, because there’s a lot more
to a novel than the words themselves.
There’s you know, a novel is a deeply layered
thing, and part of your understanding of the
novel is your understanding of the interrelationships
between the layers, especially if it’s a
profound novel.
I mean I think that’s why we have this sense
of depth in artistic and literary works.
If the work is deep then it has many, many
layers, and the more layers it has interacting
at the same time, the more it’s a useful
representation of the essential elements of
being, and so the more meaningful it is to
us.
So, that’s all to say that there are modes
of communication that provide us with information
that we can’t articulate but that we still
act as if that information is valid.
And you might say, well, valid for what, what
exactly is it doing, what is it representing,
what kind of information is it offering that’s
so compelling?
And what’s so interesting about it is the
kind of information that we’re talking,
that information is so compelling, that you’ll
pay to expose yourself to it.
You know, it’s a rare lecture that you go
to and have to pay for the lecture itself.
I mean, you’ll come to the university and
you’ll get your degree, but if you had your
option on a Saturday afternoon, or a Saturday
night, let’s say, it’s relatively unlikely
that you would attend a lecture, and certainly
even more than unlikely that you would pay
to attend one, but you’ll certainly pay
to go somewhere to dance to music.
And, you know, why that is, is not obvious.
You say, well it’s entertaining.
It’s like, yeah it’s entertaining alright
but it’s a lot more than that, and I think
that dismissing things that are enjoyable
as entertainment, which means that they’re
sort of peripheral, they’re unimportant
in some sense is a real, it’s a real terrible
habit of psychologists.
So for example, when Steven Pinker wrote his
book…
it’s a book on language and unfortunately
I can’t remember its name at the moment…
he devoted one chapter at the end basically,
to non-verbal cultural forms and he talked
about them as epiphenomenal, fundamentally.
You know, they’re just a by-product.
And I think that’s deeply wrong, I think
that our culture actually grew out of dance
and drama and music, and science came way,
way later than that.
I was watching an old video today.
It was of The Animals playing House of the
Rising Sun in 1964.
It’s a pretty good video, and it’s a great
old song.
I mean, they didn’t write it, it’s an
old blues song, but it’s a great old song
and they do a pretty good job of it.
And the audience was full of girls and they
were screaming madly away.
Now it wasn’t quite as bad as The Beatles,
which was completely unbelievable, but it
was still, you know, a fairly continual din
of delighted shrieks.
And, you know, I think that’s extremely
interesting because you’d never see that
at a scientific conference [students’ laughter].
Well, it’s strange, eh?
Like, there isn’t anything else that elicits
that kind of response.
Maybe sports to some minimal degree, but certainly
with nowhere near the same amount of enthusiasm.
And you know, I mean, that’s been happening
for a long time, it wasn’t merely a phenomenon
of the 60s.
I mean, I suspect it’s been happening ever
since there’s been wandering minstrels,
and that’s a very, very long time.
And I suspect that those wandering minstrels
left many offspring behind them [laughter].
And well, what’s interesting about that
is, obviously part of the reason that human
beings can sing is because we’ve selected
each other for that ability, right?
I mean there’s something very attractive
about someone who’s artistically gifted.
And the idea that women will do backflips
for a singer is not necessarily any negative
comment on their ability to evaluate what’s
important, it might be quite the reverse.
So anyways, the point is that there’s lots
of different ways that we can communicate
information.
And you might say well it’s only simple
information that can be conveyed that way,
and you have to convey the complex information
in more formal forms, scientific and philosophical,
but I think that’s exactly backwards.
I think we get to articulate the simple stuff
first, which is only what you expect, right?
Because when you’re mastering something
difficult, like the unfolding of being, the
probability that you’re going to get to
the simple things first and the complicated
things later is pretty much 100%.
And I mean, different fields advance at different
speeds, but the artists and musicians get
to the complex matters far before the scientists
and the engineers.
And it has to be that way.
One of the deep things I learned from Jung
was that, as our knowledge expands out into
the unknown, there are people operating at
the periphery, and so they really have one
foot in the unknown and one foot on dry land,
so to speak.
And some of them are more in the water than
the others.
And the ones almost submerged up to their
neck, when they tell you what they’re seeing,
it has to be poetic and musical and artistic,
because it’s so far beyond our capacity
to articulate, that we can’t represent it
in words.
And so all that can happen is that the artist
can get hold of it, and maybe the people who
are prone to religious-like sentiments, at
least experiences, which seems to be associated
by the way with the trait openness.
To have the actual religious experience, rather
than to be an adherent of the dogma, which
is associated with low openness.
So for Jung, it was the artists and the entrepreneurs,
because they’re the same people, who were
at the forefront of the expansion of what
we know into what is unknown.
And I think you can see echoes of that in
the way in which cities are rejuvenated.
Because what happens, you can certainly see
this in Toronto, is that a part of the city
that has some architectural or contextual
interest but is badly run down, starts to
get…
at some point, you know, the artistic people
show up and they think “Hey!
This is kind of cool.
If we just did this to it there’d really
be something to it”.
And it usually doesn’t hurt that the rents
are low because of course artists never have
any money.
So then they go in there and civilise the
hell out of it.
And of course, they’re renting, and that
jacks up the property value, and then the
people who are a little less open but kind
of interested in art start flowing in behind
them.
And then soon the whole place is rejuvenated
and expensive, and of course the artists have
to go somewhere else.
But that’s a very interesting phenomenon,
because what’s happening is that even in
the cities they’re taking chaos and turning
it into order, and that’s what artists do.
Now that’s all to tell you that there are
different ways of transmitting and representing
information, and that you can incorporate
the information without any articulated notion
of what you’re doing.
So of course that’s the case, because otherwise
you’d have to claim that you understand
everything that you do and can articulate
it, and that’s just wrong, you know.
You have a theory of yourself but it’s not
a very accurate theory, which is why you’re
always doing things that are strange as far
as you’re concerned, which is also extremely
bizarre.
It’s like, who the hell are you if you can’t
even control your own behaviour?
And what does it mean to control it, and what
does it mean to not control it?
These are very, very complex and strange issues.
Alright, so I think the best way into this
is actually from an evolutionary perspective.
And I’m not convinced that this is correct
but I think there’s something to it.
So when you think about the nature of experience,
then you think, well the nature of experience
is quite different for different sorts of
creatures.
And one of the primary differences between
creatures is the degree to which they’re
capable of social interaction and then of
complex social interaction.
And primates generally speaking are very social
creatures.
They live in troops, or packs, like dogs.
Which is why we can get along with dogs, because
we understand each other.
Being hierarchical troop animals, we understand
dogs, and they understand us, and they can
fit right in, pretty much.
And we’re very, very good at figuring out
where we are in the troop.
And by ‘we’ I mean primates.
I mean that’s going back a very, very long
period of time.
You know, monkeys and chimpanzees have very
sophisticated knowledge of the social structures
surrounding them.
They know who’s who, and they know what
status they are, they know what rank they
are, essentially.
And that’s also the case with people.
And so one of the things you might say about
people is that our reality isn’t nature,
exactly.
It’s culture.
Now, you can make the argument that you can’t
really distinguish nature from culture, and
I believe that that’s true and untrue, in
a sense.
I think you can talk about the human and non-human
elements of reality.
And you can identify the human elements of
reality as culture, even though culture is
so old that you can also think about it as
an inevitable part of nature.
So anyway, so most of our experience in our
evolutionary past, at least let’s say for
the last several million years, we might as
well go back to when the ancestors of humans
hypothetically split off from the ancestors
of chimpanzees.
And people know very accurately when these
sorts of splits occur, by the way, because
what they do is they have some sense of the
rate of transformation of DNA.
You know it transforms and the rate is fairly
constant across time.
And so if you take two creatures and you determine
how much genetic similarity there is between
them, and how much difference, you could calculate
how far back they diverged.
And so, the fossil record helps with that,
although it’s very sparse.
But the DNA record is not very sparse at all,
in some sense, so you can be very accurate
about it.
We can even tell when people evolved or learned
to wear clothing, and the reason we can tell
that is because there’s certain kinds of
lice that can only live on clothing, and they
seem to have diverged from the lice that live
in hair about 50,000 years ago, something
like that.
And so the hypothesis is that, well, we must
have been figuring out how to wear clothes
at that point because the lice figured out
how to live in them.
So, you know, it probably took them a little
while, but I doubt if it took them very long.
You know those little creatures that breed
fast, man those things can evolve quickly,
much to our dismay.
So okay, so a big part of the experiential
field of advanced primates is the social world.
And so we could call that the primate world.
And we could also say that another big part
of their experience is the non-primate world,
which would be, roughly speaking, the natural
world.
And then we could also say that the other
elements of their experience that are very
constant are their subjective being.
And we don’t know much about the subjective
being of creatures like chimpanzees, although
you can understand, I think, the subjective
being of a dog well enough to befriend the
dog.
And so you have some insight.
And I think it’s also reasonable to assume
that…
I mean for a long time people were unwilling
to admit that animals had a soul, that was
the first problem.
But after that, that they were conscious.
And even the behaviourists fought that notion.
But I think the simplest thing to do is to
assume that animals and human beings are the
same, except when you can prove that they’re
different.
Because we share so much of our evolutionary
past then the logical inference is that if
you think a dog is doing something sort of
like you would do in that situation, and feeling
that way, it probably is, with certain exceptions
for species difference.
And if that wasn’t the case I don’t think
that you could have a relationship with the
dog, or cat.
You can’t have much of a relationship with
a lizard, although there are lizards, bearded
dragons in particular, that are social.
They like to lay on top of each other and
they hang around together.
And you can actually have more of a relationship
with them.
And apparently the same is true for iguanas.
So you can go quite a ways backwards in evolutionary
time, and still have enough similarity between
you and the creature that you’re interacting
with, so you can get a pretty good sense of
at least some element of their being.
And so, the idea that subjective, or subjectivity,
is a very ancient part of our experience,
seems to me to be a perfectly reasonable supposition.
We certainly know that it’s been around,
in all likelihood, for at least 150,000 years
(on the conservative side), because there
have been human beings that are essentially
identical to us, from a genetic perspective,
going back 150,000 years.
But I think you’d have to be a pretty harsh
judge to assume that higher-order primates
like chimps don’t have some consciousness.
And you know, and some limited self-consciousness.
You know, if you mark a chimp’s nose with
lipstick and then show it a mirror, it will,
at least sometimes, take the lipstick off
its nose.
Although I’ve seen a gorilla try to fight
with a mirror.
Well no, I haven’t personally seen that,
but I’ve seen a very good video of that
happening.
But I think the gorilla in it would eventually
figure out that it was him in the mirror.
Dogs will recognise a dog in the mirror, but
they seem to ignore their reflection very,
very rapidly.
And I don’t know if that means that they
have a very rudimentary self-consciousness,
and that they figure out that that dog is
them, or if the dog just doesn’t smell like
a dog, and then the dog thinks “well it
can’t be a dog because it doesn’t smell
like a dog”.
And dogs probably think that something is
a dog because of how it smells, and not because
of how it looks.
I think that’s why dogs don’t seem to
have any sense of relative size.
Because you can get a little Chihuahua barking
like mad at a Great Dane and you think, really?
That’s going to work, is it?
But the dog doesn’t seem to have a clue
about that, like he’s perfectly happy.
And the Great Dane, weirdly enough, will often
back off.
Anyway, okay, so we’ve been in a social
world, a deeply social world for a long time,
and I’m also going to make the presupposition
that we’ve been in the stratified social
world for a very long period of time.
And I think you could call that, if you wanted
to, and I would never want to, by the way,
you could call that the patriarchy.
I think that I wouldn’t call it that because
that’s not what it is.
But I think that the fact that it’s called
that, and that that’s accepted as a reasonable
representation is actually a consequence of
the action of an archetype.
And the archetype is that, it’s the archetype
of the terrible Great Father, actually.
Because you think, well there’s a social
structure with striations in it, and that
has advantages and disadvantages.
And the advantages are that you can live in
it.
And the disadvantages are that you have to
follow the damn rules, and they might not
necessarily be to your individual benefit.
So, within a social dominance hierarchy, there’s
always a bifurcated, it also always has bifurcated
significance.
It can be good, and is good, insofar as it
protects you from, say, from threat from without,
maybe from other primates invading your territory,
for example.
But it can also be a very dismal structure
if you happen to be at the bottom of the hierarchy.
So anyways, as far as I can tell, that dominance
structure is typically represented as masculine.
And I think the reason for that, although
I’m not absolutely certain of this, I think
the reason for that is that our social hierarchies
are probably more like chimp social hierarchies
than they are like bonobo social hierarchies.
So, the bonobos are kind of a strange breed
of chimps.
I don’t know how many of you know about
them.
But the bonobos are extraordinarily sexual
and they use sex, pretty much as a standard
means of communication and tension reduction.
And there’s a lot of sex between the females
and the bonobo troops, and the use of sex
seems to bond them together in a way that
keeps male aggression under control, which
is quite interesting.
But in the chimps the fundamental dominance
hierarchy is male, although there’s a female
dominance hierarchy as well, and some females
can certainly be more dominant than some males.
But the fundamental structure seems to be
male.
And then I would also say, well, it’s probably
dependent to some degree in the primate community,
and in other social animals, on other factors.
So we know, for example, that the gender that
has the highest level of testosterone tends
to be the dominant gender.
And so in hyenas the females actually have
a higher level of testosterone.
They’re actually bigger and more aggressive
than the males, and the price they pay for
that is that they have to give birth through
a structure that’s very much like a penis,
which is not the world’s most pleasant experience,
and might account for the hyenas’ temper.
But, in human beings, you know, you see sexual
dimorphism.
Men are slightly bigger than women, and that’s
also generally characteristic of creatures
that have a dominance hierarchy that’s tilted
towards masculine.
And then the other factor seems to be that
human beings have… our infants have very,
very, very, very long periods of dependence,
and it’s very difficult to manoeuver your
way, doing anything, really, especially anything
that has to do with competition and power,
if you’re taking care of one infant, let
alone three.
And so, it seems to me that those are all
valid reasons why the primary power structures
among human beings have typically been male,
and why they’re represented as masculine.
Now there are other reasons too, because this
is a multi-faceted phenomenon.
I mean, one of the things that’s interesting
about human females is that they’re selective
maters.
Now chimp females are not selective maters,
and what that means is that the dominant males
still have most of the offspring, but the
reason for that, apparently, is because they
chase the subordinate males away from sexually
receptive females.
Although the sexually receptive females will
sneak off behind the rocks somewhere and mate
with the subordinate male.
But as long as the dominant male is around
the probability of that is quite low.
So the female chimps aren’t sexually selective,
whereas human females have concealed ovulation,
so that no one knows when they’re at their
most fertile, and they’re selective maters.
And women in every society virtually, that’s
ever been studies, have a typical pattern
of behaviour, which is that if you look at
the female dominance hierarchy and you look
at the male dominance hierarchy, the females
will mate across and up dominance hierarchies,
and the males will mate across and down.
Which works fine for both genders, because
their interests align.
But it also means that in all likelihood women
have exerted tremendous sexual selection pressure
on men, and that might be part of the reason,
of the many reasons, that we actually…
you know the theory is that the common ancestor
between chimps and humans was probably a lot
more like a chimp, a modern chimp, than like
a modern human.
So for whatever reason, we’ve undergone
a lot more transformation in the last 7 million
years than chimps have.
And one possible reason for that, and I think
it’s a highly probable reason, is that sexual
selection operated a lot more viciously, so
to speak, among humans.
It’s operated to the point where you have
twice as many female ancestors as male.
And you might think, well that can’t be
possible, but here’s how it’s possible.
It’s like, only every second man has children,
had a child, while all women had one.
Now of course, that isn’t what happened,
but on average that’s what happened.
So the proportion of men who are completely
childless in any given generation is far higher
than the proportion of women who are.
So you see an element of expendability in
males, and that’s typical across the biological
community, because you don’t need as many
males as you need females in order to keep
the population moving forward.
And one of the things that happens as a consequence
of that, at least in principle, is that males
are more behaviourally variable and variable
across a lot of dimensions, than females are.
And that’s a plus, because they’re more
variable on the upside, but it’s also negative
because they’re more prevalent on the downside.
Now there’s some substantial argument about
that in relationship to people, what the actual
implications of that are for human beings.
One potential implication is that although
women and men have equivalent IQs, the standard
deviation is slightly different.
Which means that there are more males who
are intellectually impaired, but there are
also more males who are four and five standard
deviations above the population mean.
You don’t need much of a difference in standard
deviation in order to produce radical differences
at the extreme.
So I’ll give you an example.
Males are more aggressive than females among
humans, but the effect is only about half
a standard deviation.
And so what that means is that, if you take
a female and a male randomly from a population
and you were trying to guess who was the more
aggressive of the two, most of the time, you
know about 60% of the time, the male would
be more aggressive than the female, but 40%
of the time it would be reversed.
So you know, that’s a lot of overlap.
But then here’s the rub.
So let’s say just for example, that among
the population of men and women combined,
only the most aggressive person out of a hundred
ends up in jail.
Those are all men.
Because that tilt towards aggression is enough,
so that when you go way out on the distribution,
the only people who are that extreme are men,
even though the population difference isn’t
that great.
So anyways, there’s a massive debate in
the relevant literature about the potential
consequences of that for things like cognitive
function, because there’s some indication
as well that men are more cognitively specialised
but women are more cognitively robust.
Anyways, it doesn’t really matter.
But what does matter is the fact of this permanent
dominance hierarchy.
Now, the dominance hierarchy, the male dominance
hierarchy, also has another feature.
So we already said that, you know, on average,
men are half as likely to leave offspring
as women are.
And so what that means is that all things
considered…
this isn’t…
I’m not trying to make this into a circular
argument.
Because I could say it’s the more successful
males that leave more offspring.
But then you’d say, well that’s the definition,
Darwinian definition, of success.
But I don’t mean Darwinian success, because
that’s self-evident.
What I mean is, if you look in the modern
world for example, and you try to predict
number of available sexual partners for a
given male, your best predictive measure of
that is income.
And the best predictive measure of that is
intelligence and conscientiousness.
And so, what happens is that males orient
themselves in groups, and then they compete.
And then women peel off the top.
And so the women are in a position of judgment
on men, and the judgment is the judgment of
nature.
Now, from a Darwinian perspective…
you know, when we think of nature we think
of, well it depends on who you are, but if
you’re an environmentalist you think of
a French impressionist landscape, you know,
forgetting that nature is also malarial mosquitoes
and cancer, and rats infected with bubonic
plague and all those other lovely things.
But, from a Darwinian perspective, you can
define nature much more straight-forwardly,
and more accurately, as that which selects.
Now, you know, you hear a lot about natural
selection, and natural selection basically
assumes that there is a random distribution
of alteration in genetic structure, in any
population, in any generation.
And some of those random alterations will
be more suited to that particular environment,
suited being they’ll live and they’ll
reproduce.
And genetic transformation takes place across
the millennia as the organism chases the landscape,
roughly speaking.
But Darwin, you know, Darwin, who was an unbelievably
intelligent person, was also very, very interested
in sexual selection, and as far as Darwin
was concerned, sexual selection was just as
powerful in modifying genetic structure, in
driving evolution, as natural selection.
And that’s been very underplayed by biologists.
That’s only started to switch in the last…
I would say it hasn’t switched that much
yet, but it started to switch probably in
about the last 25 years.
And that’s because the idea of sexual selection
makes things a hell of a lot more complicated.
Because, well first of all, in a standard
Darwinian account of evolution, there’s
no place for mind, there’s no place for
a creator, there’s no place for teleology.
And teleology is something moving towards
an end, a goal, right?
But the thing is, if sexual selection is operative,
and if consciousness is ancient, then mind
has been operating through sexual selection
as long as there’s been sexual selection.
So you think, do you have any choice, do you
make any choice in who your sexual partner
will be?
And the answer to that is, well it’s hardly
random, you make a choice!
And what’s interesting is that, you know,
if you take 60 people, let’s say if you
took 60 women, and you showed them a bunch
of men, and you asked them to rank them in
terms of their attractiveness, there’s going
to be very consistent rankings.
You know, I mean, we know what makes up attractive
facial features, for women and for men, it’s
easy to determine that.
What you do is you take 60 faces and you average
the features.
So you don’t get the average person, because
the average person is more like a median,
you get the averaged person.
And the averaged person has perfectly symmetrical
features that are nicely shaped, and fairly
big eyes, and they’re very nice-looking,
they’re very attractive.
And so, that means that there’s like a central
human form, in a sense, that we find attractive.
And we see this in other species, for example
there are butterflies who won’t mate with
another butterfly if it’s like a sixteenth
of an inch out of symmetry, because it’s
not a butterfly of that type, you know.
And that’s how people think too, if you
deviate from the averaged person, the less
canonically human you appear, and the less
attractive you appear.
And, you know, we’re chasing this ideal
in some sense that’s an emergent property
of the nature of our species.
And then, you know, there’s certain physical
characteristics, wide shoulders in men, and
narrow waists.
In women, it’s waist-to-hip ratio, a very
common marker of beauty, across cultures,
and across body types, interestingly enough.
So, if you take thin women and heavier women,
and you get men to rate the attractiveness
of the women within that category, the heavy
women and the light women who have a waist-to-hip
ratio of about 0.68 are the ones that are
judged most attractive physically.
And so, that actually correlates, by the way,
with fertility, because the abdominal fat
in a young woman is a sign of ill health and
also a marker of decreased likelihood of conception.
Now none of this is operating consciously,
obviously, it’s deeply wired into us, it’s
part of our mediate perception.
But it still does indicate that there’s
an ideal, like a platonic ideal, lurking at
the back of our minds, against whom we compare
everyone that we meet.
And then you might say, well what’s the
nature of that platonic ideal, and that’s
a very, very complicated question.
You know, I would say that you could almost
literally claim that the…
well you can certainly claim that the ideal
male is represented in mythology as a hero.
And that’s actually what mythology is about,
it’s about representing ideal patterns of
behaviour, so it’s hardly surprising.
And so, you know, if you go to a movie, and
it’s a romance, and there’s the main lead
character that you’re supposed to fall in
love with (if you happen to be the kind of
person that would fall in love with that kind
of person), then he’s going to act out a
particular pattern of behaviour.
And the pattern of behaviour is quite identifiable.
So for example he’s going to move forward
and explore, and not hide and cower.
And the probability that he’s going to be
creative is very high, and the probability
that he’s going to be good-looking and strong
is very high.
And so, those are archetypal features.
And those aren’t all the archetypal features,
because those are, in some sense, those are
the self-evident ones.
But you know, people are also evaluating each
other for things like intelligence, and personality,
and character.
And you could say in some sense that men are
competing to be the best man, and women are
watching the competition to take the man who
wins on the presupposition that he wouldn’t
win if he wasn’t the best man.
It’s a very, very intelligent strategy.
Because why not outsource the problem.
Let the men sort it out, well as I say, it’s
too cognitively complex to compute.
You could say that the male dominance hierarchy
is equivalent to the stock market.
It’s exactly equivalent to the stock market.
The stocks are always competing with one another,
and with every other commodity, for primacy
of price and value, and that’s exactly what
happens with male competition.
So one of the things that we’ve just discovered
in my lab, this is Caitlyn Burton’s work,
it’s very cool, is that we took… we were
trying to understand the fundamental sub-structure
of conservatism vs. liberalism.
And I’m going to speak in terms of conservatism,
because that’s how we construed the data,
although we could’ve done the reverse if
we were going to construe liberalism.
And what we did was we took, we got a bunch
of people to sit down and write down a bunch
of statements that they though conservatives
vs. liberals would disagree with.
You know, I think we had, I don’t remember
how many statements, 300 statements, something
like that.
We had a lot of people generate them and take
them from news items and so forth, because
we didn’t want any bias in the initial question
set.
Or we didn’t want a bias that wasn’t there
in the actual world.
So we had many people do this, and then we
gave these questions to many, many people
online, in a variety of stages.
And we extracted those out that seemed to
best fit the data, and then assessed them
for the utility in predicting things like
party membership or voting behaviour.
And so we got a good structure, it makes a
lot of sense, and what we found with regards
to conservatism was that there was an ethnocentrism
factor, it was the third and weakest factor,
and that would be associated with in-group
preference vs. out-group derogation.
So those are anti-immigrant people, fundamentally,
you know, and they’re, well they’re ethnocentric.
That’s the simplest way to explain it.
And then the second smallest factor was religious
traditionalism.
And most of this was done with Americans,
for a variety of reasons.
And that was really where the fundamentalist
Christians nested.
And not everyone… that was not only a factor
made up of fundamentalist Christian beliefs,
but they loaded heavily.
Those were people who weren’t for stem cell
research, they were anti-abortion, they were
anti-gay marriage.
Or they were pro-traditional, which is how
they see themselves.
And then, the largest factor was a factor
that we called ‘masculine independence’.
And it was more characteristic of men, and
what it basically consisted of was an attitude
that winners win and losers lose, and that’s
just how it should be.
So it was the men who… the personality predictors,
one of them was extroverted assertiveness…
hunting and the right to own firearms also
loaded on this factor, but it was masculine
competitiveness, I think, is the best way
of thinking about it.
And I think it’s a good illustration of
the kind of individual attitude that makes
you more likely to attempt to climb up dominance
hierarchies and dominate them from the top
down.
And that’s not necessarily something that
would be associated with factors like compassion.
Well, I’ll leave it at that.
It’s just that you can see…
I’m telling you that because you can see
how these proclivities manifest themselves
in all sorts of areas of behaviour.
I can tell you something else that’s very
interesting about men and violence.
I don’t know if I can get this story straight
because it’s been a while since I told it.
So there’s this interesting phenomenon,
that’s very characteristic of societies,
I believe pretty much everywhere it’s been
studied.
Now, you can calculate an index called the
Gini coefficient.
And the Gini coefficient is a number that
represents how much inequality of income distribution
there is in a given geographical area.
So you could calculate a Gini coefficient
for a street or an area in a city, or a city,
or a state, or a country, you can do it at
all those levels.
And what you find is that, you know you always
hear this idea that poverty causes crime.
That’s a classic left-wing idea.
But it’s wrong, it’s seriously wrong.
And it’s importantly wrong.
And it’s definitively wrong, not only that.
So there’s no argument about this, it’s
already been established.
What causes crime, especially aggressive crime,
is relative poverty, and relative poverty
is not the same thing as poverty at all.
It’s seriously not the same thing.
Poverty is when you don’t have enough to
eat.
Relative poverty is when the guy next door
has a much better car than you.
And there’s lots of relative poverty in
the United States, and there’s some absolute
poverty, but even the absolute poverty in
the United States is nothing like the absolute
poverty say in places like India or sub-Saharan
Africa, where absolute poverty means you have
nothing.
Now, what’s really interesting about the
Gini coefficient is that if you go to places
where everyone, roughly speaking, is poor,
say by national standards…
I think South Dakota was often used as an
example, or maybe one of the Maritime Provinces…
like Newfoundland, where there’s low average
income but it’s pretty flat distribution,
there’s almost no crime.
And if you go to places where everyone’s
rich then there’s almost no crime.
But if you go places where there’s poor
people and moderately well-off people, and
rich people, and the distribution is really
steep, then the rate of aggressive behaviour
among young men, and it’s usually within
their own ethnic group, starts to sky-rocket
out of control.
And the reason for that seems to be that,
if the dominance hierarchy is too steep, then
the young men have no likelihood of climbing
to a dominant position while playing the standard
social game.
And so what they do is turn to aggression,
to make their mark on the world.
And it works, too, that’s the other thing.
Make no mistake about it, if you’re looking
for status where status is hard to achieve,
and you’re the meanest, toughest guy around,
and, you know, around a bunch of people who,
like you, don’t have much money, then you’re
going to benefit from that status.
It works.
Yeah?
Would that be part of the reason why… because
I know that, I think that violent crime rate
in the US is higher than it is in Canada,
would that be part of the reason why?
Sure, yeah, I mean you can make a real conservative
argument for making sure that, you know that
conservatives are very anti-income distribution,
and we figure that’s because of the guys
that have this male independence, you know
they have this male independence factor, they
don’t want to be distributing resources
to people who are down the dominance hierarchy
because they want them down the dominance
hierarchy!
They want there to be a difference between
the people on top and the people on the bottom,
so that they can be the people on top, so
that it increases their relative attractiveness.
Like it’s a perfectly logical game.
And they presume that, well the rules are
set up, and like every man can go for it,
do his best, and the winner wins and the loser
loses, and that’s just how it is, and “don’t
ask me to fix it because I don’t want to.
And besides that I find it distasteful to
attempt to fix it”, more than that, right,
because it’s a moral issue, it’s not just
an intellectual issue.
So you can make a case, however, from the
conservative point of view, especially with
regards to, say, beliefs in religious traditionalism,
and the desire to maintain social stability,
that you shouldn’t let income distribution
become too unequal.
Like one of the big things your society has
to do is to make sure that doesn’t get out
of hand, because it tends to get out of hand,
it tends towards a few people having everything
and almost everyone else having nothing.
In a sense, it’s a natural consequence of
economic progression, which is actually something
that Marx pointed out.
Although an Italian named Pareto had figured
it out at approximately the same time, and
I think with a lot more conceptual clarity.
But, the more unequal you let your society
get, the higher the probability of death,
roughly speaking, through violent causes.
But I’m telling you why it is that, you
know, men want to climb the dominance hierarchy,
and the reason they want to climb the dominance
hierarchy is that they get access to women.
I was going to, actually ask earlier in the
discussion, when you were talking about the
familiar and the unfamiliar and the structure.
So it seems like we all want to live within
a structure, but we don’t want the rules
to apply to ourselves.
Well, we have this contradictory problem,
we want to be protected by the structure but
we want to advance our position within it.
And so that means, what that should mean,
and this is I think the definition of civilised
behaviour, is that you’re allowed to advance
your position within the structure as long
as you don’t disrupt it negatively.
And I think that most people do do that.
In fact I think people in civilised countries
do that so effectively that it’s an absolute,
incomprehensible miracle.
I can’t understand how or why it ever got
established.
But like a psychopath will climb the ladder
and cut the rungs off underneath him, fundamentally.
He doesn’t even care if the damn thing maintains
itself.
You know, he’s perfectly willing to have
it destroyed after he’s exhausted it.
But if everyone acted like that or even if
a substantial number of people acted like
that, the whole thing would come to a halt,
virtually in no time flat.
So I mean, why… see, you might…
here’s a reason…
you know, because one of the things we were
talking about is masculine violence.
Now the thing about masculine violence is
that it only tends to emerge in situations
where there don’t seem to be any other reasonably
viable means of advancing status.
So it’s not reasonable to say that men are
aggressive.
You can say that on average men are more aggressive
than women.
And you can also say that if you put men in
a situation where they have no, where they
can see status differences but they have no
means of moving forward, that they’re likely
to turn to aggression as a way of establishing
dominance.
And then you can say that, the reason for
that is that it makes them more attractive,
the fundamental reason.
Yeah?
Yeah, I’d just like to add on, I read this
article once that talks about how polygamous
societies are more violent than monogamous
ones.
Yeah, absolutely.
I was going to say maybe it’s because when
one guy has two wives that means that 50%
of the population has no wives, no access
to sex.
Yeah that’s exactly right, the evolutionary
psychology explanation for the pathology of
polygamy is that once you let it establish
itself then then men get ultra-violent.
So would you say that monogamy would almost
be a basis for civilised society?
Many people have said that, and yes I think
you can make a strong case for that.
And I think the fundamental reason is the
one you just pointed out.
You know the idea is, well, would you rather
have one woman, or die, you know?
Sorry no, that’s not quite right.
It’s more like, would you be willing to
limit yourself to one partner or have a shot
at many partners but a much higher probability
of dying.
Right, and you know, some guys will take that.
They’ll take the high-risk approach.
So now, this doesn’t eliminate the difference
in individual differences in determining who’s
going to be aggressive, because what will
happen is that as the Gini coefficient pressure
rises, the more aggressive men, the men who
are more aggressive by nature, will get more
aggressive first.
So you can imagine, it’s a threshold phenomenon,
in some sense.
And what I should tell you as well is that
the relationship between the Gini coefficient
and male-on-male homicide isn’t 0.2 or 0.3,
which is the correlation that you’d get
if you were predicting something like that
using personality.
It’s like 0.8 or 0.9.
It’s like it eats up all of it, it’s the
explanation.
So it’s a huge effect, it’s so big an
effect that you can basically say that oh
well, we figured that out.
Although psychologists never know when they’ve
figured anything out, and they keep endlessly
retesting it over and over and over, because
you know, we don’t know how to bring our
science to a stop.
But if you don’t accept the Gini coefficient-aggression
data, that’s like, you might as well throw
the rest of social sciences out the window,
because the effect is unbelievably powerful.
What geographical area does this take place
in?
It depends…
you can do it on any level of analysis.
You can do it by county, you can do it by
city, you can do it by state, and you can
do it by country, and it works on all of those
levels
Student: Like, it predicts aggression, almost?
You bet.
Yeah.
And that’s a great question.
I mean, the methodologically sophisticated
studies have done exactly that, to ensure
that it’s actually this phenomenon rather
than other factors that might be operative
in that particular geographical area.
So countries with a higher Gini coefficient
are more violent, and cities within that country
that have a higher than average Gini coefficient
for that country are more violent on average.
It’s a very, very robust finding.
Alright, so we’re going to say, for the
sake of argument, that you’ve got the male
dominance hierarchy, and it’s represented
as masculine.
Now, one of the things Jung said, now he thought
that women carried an image of men in their
unconscious.
And he thought that the image that women carried
of men in their unconscious was a group of
men, not an individual man.
He called that the animus.
Whereas he believed that the image of women
that men carried in their collective unconscious
was of a single woman, and he called that
the anima.
Now I’m just telling you that, I’m not
going to justify it, or even discuss it, but
I just want you to keep that in the back of
your mind.
So I guess part of the reason I’m telling
you that, come to think of it, is that I think
it may provide some insight into why the idea
of the patriarchy has become such a well-accepted
notion.
Because it is an archetypal notion, but it’s
a one-sided archetypal notion.
Okay, so back to sexual selection.
Now, we already talked about the fact that
biologists perhaps were uncomfortable with
the idea of sexual selection, because it brings
a non-random factor into evolution.
A seriously non-random factor, because you
have to go back as far as you can in history
to where there was no choice, on the part
of the organism, to attribute evolution to
natural selection alone.
And you have to go back a long ways back,
as I said, even butterflies are perfectly
capable of distinguishing between a high-quality
butterfly partner, in butterfly terms, and
a low-quality butterfly partner.
And you know, insects have been around for
a very, very long time.
So we have no idea, what that actually means
is that we have no idea what role choice has
made in the evolutionary process.
But one thing that you can infer is that the
reason human beings are the way they are now,
and not like chimps or human ancestors, is
because the sexual selection process got started,
and it was intense.
And so, as a consequence of that, here we
are.
And so, you know, maybe it was a good thing.
Although it’s very hard, in some sense,
on all those people who failed.
And that’s, you know, roughly speaking,
twice as many men as women.
So then that all raises the question, like
who exactly is responsible for the male dominance
hierarchy?
Because you could say it’s male competitiveness,
but you could also say, yeah well it’s an
inevitable function of female selection.
Which is not an argument that you hear very
often.
But I think it’s a very difficult argument
to escape from.
And that leads us to our next hypothesis.
So we’re going to say that the masculine
dominance hierarchy is represented as masculine.
I’m going to call that The Great Father
for the time being.
And that’s the permanent dominance hierarchy
of men, and it’s always there, it moves
through history.
It’s different men all the time, but the
men slot in and out as they are born and die,
but the structure itself stays intact across…
forever.
It’s always there.
It’s been there at least for millions of
years, so for our purposes we’ll just call
it permanent.
It’s a permanent part of experience, and
it’s a big part of it.
And you know, as culture gets more and more…
covers larger and larger expanses of territory,
gets more and more sophisticated, it’s an
ever larger part of reality.
I mean, most of us spend almost all our time
coping with the dominance hierarchy, and almost
none of our time combatting nature.
You know, you get wet for a little while and
that’s it, you know, but most of the problems
that you would face in a purely natural environment,
you’re so distant from them that you could
hardly imagine, you can’t even imagine what
it would be like, in some sense, to be in
an environment like that.
Yeah?
I have a question.
Like your explanation of what drives men to
become competitive and vindictive of the hierarchy…
what drives women?
Like for example there’s an aggressive nature
of women and there’s some sort of competitiveness
in women, let’s say at the University of
Toronto.
So
what is driving women to try to elevate their
level in the hierarchy?
Well, that’s a good question.
So the way I would answer that question is
two-fold.
So the question was what drives women to move
to the top of the hierarchy?
It’s something that’s worth discussing.
So if anybody objects to what I’m going
to say, then please do, because I’m not,
you know, dishing this out as received truth,
it’s…
I’ve been trying to figure this out and
this is what it looks like to me.
The first thing is that I think there are…
male and female dominance hierarchies both
exist but they’re different.
And that females compete with each other intensely,
but they don’t compete for the same things,
and they don’t compete the same way.
So let me tell you a little story, this is
a bit of a divergence, but it’s an interesting
point.
And one of the questions I’ve always been
asked in this class… because I’m going
to lay out a hero story, and the fundamental
hero archetype, and the hero is masculine
in mythology… and so the women always ask,
well what about the role of the woman?
And it’s like, it’s very, very complex,
which of course, all you women already know,
because it is very, very complex.
But it isn’t something that…
first of all I don’t think it’s a question
that would’ve been asked before the invention
of the birth control pill.
Because we know what the archetypal female
is, prior to that.
It’s the Virgin Mary with child, it’s
a virgin with child.
Which means that the unit for woman is ‘woman
with child’.
It’s not woman, it’s woman with child.
And, well, it’s obvious why that is, because
as soon as you become a woman, in most societies,
you have a child.
Before that, you’re a girl, and that’s,
you know, that’s in some sense irrelevant,
in terms of your destiny.
Now you might say, well what’s your archetypal
pattern if you’re not a mother?
Well, the way it looks to me is that there’s
two archetypes for personal development, for
the personal path, roughly speaking.
There’s the hero, and that would be the
person that explores the unknown and discovers
something of value and brings it back and
distributes it to the community.
So it’s like a hunting…
it’s probably predicated on a hunting platform,
because our bodies are hunting platforms,
basically.
And one theory about what men did, which is
a very probable theory, is that they went
out and hunted for meat.
And chimps like meat, they’ll eat it whenever
they can, although they’re not very good
hunters.
But they will definitely eat meat.
And human beings are so good at hunting that
we probably…
well, for example, we probably wiped out the
mammoths.
And when human beings came into North America,
there were as many different kinds of large
animal in North America as there were in Africa,
and human beings killed all of them.
And that was just with… you know, like they
didn’t have our notion of technologically
sophisticated weapons, it was bows and arrows
and clubs and spears.
Nonetheless, they got rid of everything, you
know.
Large cats, giant beavers, mammoths… we’re
very, very, very, very dangerous.
Anyways, there’s another archetype, I would
say it’s a maternal archetype in a sense,
and one of the things that’s very interesting
about human males is that they’re quite
maternal, by comparison to other animals.
So for example, the mother bear doesn’t
have the male bear, the boar… is it boars
and sows with bears?
I think it is.
Anyways, you keep the cub away from the male,
because he’ll kill them.
Now, not all males will do that but many will,
they don’t have any filial attachment.
And that’s the case for many but not all
complex mammals.
Pair bonding on a permanent basis is relatively
rare, but joint provision of children, that’s
exceedingly rare.
And men are pretty good at taking care of
children.
I would say they’re not as good at taking
care of infants as women are, because they
don’t have the full range of resources at
hand.
And they’re not, I don’t think they have
the same kind of immediate intuitive understanding
of, or attraction to, babies that women have.
I think that switch is around the age of two
or two and a half, when the kids can engage
in rough-and-tumble play.
Because men are much more likely to engage
in rough-and-tumble play than women are, and
rough-and-tumble play seems to be one of the
things that civilises children.
And it’s partly because, you know one of
the things you have to learn when you’re
a child is what actually hurts you and what
can be ignored, and what actually hurts someone
else and what can be ignored.
And the best way to learn that is in rough-and-tumble
play.
Because what happens is that if you’re playing
with a kid, they get more and more excited
and they do more and more crazy things, until
they do something that either hurts them or
hurts you, and then you have to say, look,
you can’t do that.
And it’s like a dance in a sense, you know,
when you’re playing with a kid.
And you have to let them win fairly frequently,
because otherwise they don’t continue the
game.
And you can tell that because if the game
is going well then they’re laughing with
insane life, because kids just love rough-and-tumble
play.
And they love crazy things and catch them
and they think that’s just great.
But partly what you’re doing is you’re
extending their body in all sorts of ways
and getting them to learn, in an embodied
sense, where their limits are and where the
limits of other people are.
And that’s embodied.
And children who haven’t had that, man they’re
just so awkward, it’s unbelievable.
You know, they might have some hypothetical
sense of how to interact with another person,
but they don’t have an embodied sense of
it, and they can’t tell the difference between
what hurts them and what doesn’t.
Because often a young child, if they’re
startled, they’ll start to cry.
And then you can say, well that didn’t hurt,
and then they’ll notice, well yeah it didn’t
hurt, and they’ll stop crying.
But if they haven’t had their limits tested,
they’ll cry at anything unexpected, even
if it doesn’t hurt.
And that’s not good, because if you cry
under all conditions the probability that
you’ll make friends when you’re three
is zero.
Because another kid will start playing with
you and maybe playing rough, and if you burst
into tears, you know, several times, the kid’s
just going to go somewhere else and find a
different playmate.
You know, they’ll say you’re just a baby.
Which is roughly, exactly accurate…
roughly exactly [laughter]… roughly accurate!
Anyways, back to the archetypal representation.
I think really the way to think about it is
that for men, the hero archetype is the archetype
that’s dominant and in the forefront, and
the maternal archetype is subordinate and
in the background, I mean inside their own
psyches.
Whereas with women it’s reversed.
So each of the genders can play the role of
the other gender but there’s a tilt in each
of them towards the… what would you say?
Well I would say towards typical gender-normative
behaviour.
Now the social constructivists believe that
no such thing exists, but those people are
so pathological that even considering what
they have to say is a mistake.
So, you know they act as if there is no biology
and everything’s cultural, and it’s like,
well no, that’s just not right.
Now what biology means in practice and what
you should do about it, that’s a whole different
question, but to think of all these differences
as socially… height differences between
men and women are not socially constructed,
and they’re relevant.
And the upper-body strength differences between
men and women are not socially constructed,
and they’re relevant too!
So one of the things I was wondering about,
maybe you guys can help me clarify this or
tell me where I’m not thinking about this
properly, and if you think there’s any…
if I’m missing something let me know.
One of the things my daughter said, she watched
my son one day have a fight with his best
friend.
It was a physical fight, you know.
His best friend did something that my best
friend didn’t regard as appropriate and
so he hit him, and then there was a fight.
And then three days later they were friends
again.
And my daughter said to me that she was very
annoyed by that, which wasn’t the fight
exactly, but the fact that they could have
a fight and then they were friends again three
days later, because she said that that option
wasn’t available to women, right?
And the option is, the option that the men
have is, “well if you get out of hand I’ll
just sock you one”, and then we’ll have
established where the boundaries of behaviour
begin and end.
And I would say that in my experience, if
I’m talking to someone who’s self-confident
and masculine and accomplished, there’s
always an undercurrent of potential violence.
It’s an undercurrent.
And that’s actually an undercurrent of respect,
which means that there’s things that we
can do to each other in a civilised way, but
there are rules that if you break, all hell’s
going to break loose.
And one of the consequences of that is that
it doesn’t.
Now the typical bullying pattern for women
in high school and junior high is reputation
destruction.
And I’m wondering, what are the implications
for the conduct of behaviour if there is no
recourse to aggression to solve disputes?
Because they don’t get solved.
You know, I’ve tried to analyse what it
means to say ‘no’ to someone, because
‘no’ means something.
‘No’ means…
well if you tell a child ‘no’, what you’re
basically telling the child, as far as I can
tell, is if you continue doing that something
you won’t like will happen to you.
And if you’re civilised and say no what
happens is you say no a couple of times and
then instead of devaluing the word, which
is what you do if you just said it over and
over a hundred times with no consequences,
you take action that’s non-verbal.
And so one of the things you might do is remove
the child from the situation, or you might
put them on the steps.
Or maybe you put them on the steps and they
run away, so you have to hold them on the
steps.
But the point is, the point to the child is,
there are limits, and if you exceed them,
you will be physically controlled.
What if there’s no option for physical control?
What happens?
Well I don’t know the answer to that, I
don’t know what women do about that but
I also don’t know what men do about that
in relationship to women.
So I was watching something the other day,
it was this…
I posted it on my Twitter account as an example
of animus possession.
So a woman and a man were having a dispute
on the street.
It was a political dispute.
And this particular woman, the way she was
behaving towards this particular man, was
such that had she been a man, and had he been
a man, he would have definitely hit her.
Because she was right in his face, and she
was cursing at him and swearing and calling
him an idiot.
And really being hyper-aggressive.
And of course, he couldn’t do anything about
it.
So then I was watching that and I was thinking,
just exactly what are you supposed to do in
a situation like that?
Because you’re screwed no matter what you
do.
If you’re on the male side, it’s like,
you certainly can’t intervene physically.
It’s like you’re dead in the water instantly,
instantly, in your eyes, the eyes of society,
and in the woman’s eyes, instantly, if you
move past the boundary.
If you leave, well, there’s no glory in
running away, that’s for sure.
So what exactly is supposed to happen?
I have no idea what’s supposed to happen
in a situation like that.
I think what happens, what will happen over
time, is that men just won’t put themselves
in those situations.
I think what the male would have to do in
that situation is behave like a woman would,
in a female dominance hierarchy.
So he stands there and takes it and afterwards
goes off and bad-mouths her to her social
circle.
That’s a form of aggression.
Right, right, but you know that’s definitely
not seen as an admirable form of behaviour
among men.
I mean, I don’t think it’s an admirable
form of behaviour, period.
But I mean, you know, aggression is often
not admirable, so that’s fine.
Yeah?
I think that when you take away emotion, like
when someone’s acting really aggressively
towards you and you reserve your emotion,
it gives them a lot less to feed off of, and
that ends up taking power away in a similar
way that aggression does.
Because people react aggressively and they
want feedback that gives them more excitement…
Oh definitely.
Oh yeah it would’ve been a real victory
for her if she would’ve gotten slapped.
Absolutely, because it would prove everything
she said instantly.
Yeah, but when you dismiss, power’s gone.
So then you have all the power.
Yeah, yeah.
Well I think that that would be a reasonably
effective strategy for a street confrontation
like that.
I’m not so sure how well it would work in
a prolonged competition inside a company,
for example.
In a hierarchy, yeah, because you know the
truth of the matter is that men have no idea
how to treat women if they’re in male power
hierarchies.
They have no idea how to treat them.
And that’s because we have no idea how to
do that.
No one has any idea how to do that.
It’s only been happening, in any pronounced
sense, for about, well, on a societal level,
really probably since the mid-70s.
You know, it’s three generations.
It’s a drop in the bucket.
And it’s a very, very difficult thing to
sort out.
So, I mean part of the reason I’ve been
thinking about these sorts of things is because
I’ve been very interested in the fact that
men have been doing very badly in junior high
and high school, and they’re bailing out
of universities like mad.
At the rate it’s going there’ll be almost
no men in most disciplines within ten years.
I mean you can tell that even in this class.
It’s funny because on my YouTube videos
I look at the gender distribution for viewing
and it’s 80% male, which is interesting
to me.
I’m not sure exactly why that is.
But in lots of fields it’s 80:20 women already,
and I can’t see why that won’t…
I think that’ll accelerate as we move forward,
rather than slowing down.
Alright, so anyways, back to sexual selection
and the power hierarchy.
Now from a Darwinian perspective, one of the
things you might do is call whatever selects
‘nature’.
And so when we think of nature and we think
about nature from a scientific perspective,
we don’t even think about humans as agents
of nature, right?
We tend to think of the human being as something
that stands against nature.
That’s in mythology.
It’s like, the human being against the natural
world, it’s a very common plot in movies
and stories.
So it’s man against nature, roughly speaking.
So we tend to think of those as separate categories.
But if women do the selection among human
beings, at least they do the intense selection,
then women are nature, for men.
And that’s exactly what the archetype is.
It’s Mother Nature.
And Mother Nature has a very vicious element,
and the vicious element of Mother Nature is
rejection.
And that can be maternal rejection, which
is, you know, certainly something that causes
a tremendous amount of trauma.
But it can also be the most fundamental form
of rejection, and the most fundamental form
of rejection is sexual rejection.
Because it means that you are judged as biologically
unworthy, roughly speaking.
And there’s other reasons why… so the
reason I’m telling you this is because I’ve
been trying to puzzle out…
what you see in mythology quite clearly is
that the dominance hierarchy is represented
as male, so culture is male, and nature is
female.
Well, why the hell would nature be female?
It’s like, okay, well I’ve given you one
reason, and I think it’s the primary reason.
There’s other reasons, because nature is
also seen as that which produces natural forms,
and of course, women produce natural forms,
so that’s a logical association.
And then, what’s the other one?
Well, we can leave it at that for the time
being.
So, now let me show you how
I think that that’s represented.
I think this is the way the world is structured
when you consider it as a place of action.
So the world as a place of action has characters,
like the elements are characters, and the
characters are engaged in dramatic behaviour.
And there are classes of characters, and as
far as I can tell, this is a reasonably comprehensive
classification of dramatic characters.
We’ll start from the inside and go out.
And you can think of any of these as primary,
by the way, and you’ll see that reflected
in different kinds of mythology.
So sometimes the maternal is primary, and
sometimes the culture is primary, and sometimes
the hero, the individual is primary.
And I think that’s because these three things
are irreducibly primary.
In that, from the perspective of consciousness,
in that, to be conscious, there has to be
you, but if you’re conscious you have to
have evolved within a culture and that’s
culture is necessarily nested in the natural
world, and so wherever there’s one there’s
all three.
And the individual’s also the thing… without
the individual there wouldn’t be any separation
between nature and culture.
So you can see the individual consciousness
is the generator of the entire structure,
but you can say that about any of the characters.
So there’s the archetypal son, because the
hero tends to be masculine, and then, it has
a… that character has a positive element
and a negative element.
And the positive element is the good person,
and the negative element is the bad person.
And I would say the archetypal representations
of those are, like, the saviour, and Satan.
And that’s basically…
there are portrayals like that in virtually
every system of mythology and religion.
Now it seems to me that in some sense Christianity,
and this was probably under the influence
of the Zoroastrians, developed the most articulated
representation of good vs. evil at the individual
level.
And that’s why you can identify two fundamental
characters in the Christian story, so to speak,
that play out these roles.
And they’re seen as eternal adversaries
locked in battle across time.
And that would be, the battle takes place
in the natural world, the battle takes place
in the cultural world, and the battle takes
place within, as well.
And you can see that reflected in stories
all the time, because, you know, it’s so
frequently the case that the hero, the super-hero
has his nemesis.
And it’s the guy that he’s extraordinarily
well-matched with who continuously tests his
wits and whose motivation is essentially destructive.
So you see that with Batman and the Joker,
for example, or you see that with Sherlock
Holmes and Moriarty.
There’s always this pairing and that’s
partly because I think the archetypal realms
of human decision-making are something like,
are you working to make things better or are
you working to make things worse?
Are you possessed by resentment and hatred,
so that you want things to degenerate and
burn, or are you hopeful and capable of manifesting
faith in the future so that you’re working
to make things better?
And then there’s a battle in everyone, in
their own psyches, and then there’s a battle
in culture.
There’s a battle everywhere between those
two fundamental perspectives.
And then the archetypal son is the son of
the Great Father, and the Great Father represents
two things, order and tyranny.
So there’s the hero and the adversary, at
the individual level, and at the social level
there’s order and tyranny.
And so, roughly speaking, that’s either
the wise king or the despot.
And the despot is someone who tries to eat
his own sons, which is actually a fairly common
mythological trope.
And you know, you’re under the thumb of
the despot when you’re not allowed, really,
either to be hero or adversary.
You’re just a cog in the structure of the
social world.
So that’s despotism.
On the orderly side, well, culture is what
we’re sitting in right now.
I mean, this is social order that encapsulates
us.
Everything about it is social order.
I mean, there are rows, they’re roughly
linear, you know everyone’s in their place,
everyone knows what to do, we’re unbelievably
protected from virtually anything you could
possibly imagine.
And so you know, we’re in our father’s
living room, so to speak.
And in that living room, it’s a safe space…
oh God I should never have said that… [laughter]
anyways, it’s a well-protected space in
which people are able to play and explore.
And it seems to me that one of the functions
that fathers play in a family, if they’re
fulfilling their function properly, is that
what they do is they put a perimeter around
the territory, so that inside the walls, so
to speak, it’s safe, and inside the safe
walls the children can play and explore.
And in their playing and exploring they develop
their own individuality.
And so, you know, you keep the darkness at
bay, and you can certainly see that that’s
what the children want, because as soon as
you put them in a dark room, the first thing
they say is, you know, come chase the monsters
away out from underneath the bed.
And you know they wouldn’t be thinking that
if they hadn’t had an extraordinarily long
evolutionary history of being chased by monsters
in the dark.
And there are monsters in the dark, and everyone
knows that.
Which is why you tell your children not to
go play at night after it’s dark, even now.
So order and tyranny are the representations
of culture.
And the thing is that there’s a constant
interplay between those two because you can
never tell exactly when order has gone too
far and become tyranny.
Andy you can never tell really when there’s
so little order that, well the next thing
happens which is the emergence of chaos.
And chaos is the Great Mother.
And it’s creative and destructive.
And that’s nature itself.
And then on the outside, the very outside,
and this is the most complicated category
of all, is that, it’s the dragon of chaos,
and it represents something that’s very
difficult to conceptualise.
But it’s the un-configured substructure
of being that gives rise to these other categories.
So Donald Rumsfeld at one point made a very
famous comment, it became famous because it
fits an archetypal structure.
He said that there are known unknowns and
unknown unknowns.
Okay, the dragon of chaos is the unknown unknown.
It’s so unknown that you don’t even know
it’s there, but it can raise its head at
any given point.
It’s the thing that leaps out of you in
the darkness.
It’s like, is it Zika, is that the new virus?
It’s like the Zika virus.
It’s like, no one saw it coming.
It’s a completely new manifestation of being.
And so, known unknowns you can make plans
to circumvent, unknown unknowns, they’re
completely unpredictable.
And what’s so interesting, this is where
it’s so bloody complicated, because you
really have to think about things differently
to grasp what this means.
This is part of the reason why I had trouble
with this section of the course on alchemy,
because it’s so complicated that it’s…
okay, so here, think of it this way.
What is the unknown made of?
That’s a pretty weird question.
So I’ll try to walk you through it, and
we won’t get very far with this, because
we’ll have to do it 15 or 20 times I think
before it starts to become something that
you can grapple with.
Alright, so it’s September 11, 2011 and
the Twin Towers have just fallen.
Sorry, 2001, yes, 9/11.
Alright, what’s emerged?
What’s happened?
Well, one answer to that is that the towers
fell, but it’s a very, very poor answer.
Because that was an unknown unknown, I would
say, and it traumatised people.
I mean everyone, even in Toronto, walked around
in shock for about two days after that.
And the reason for that was that we didn't
know what fell.
The buildings fell, but the thing is the buildings
aren’t isolated.
Like, they’re not some abandoned buildings
standing out there in the middle of a field
in a barren wasteland in the middle of an
abandoned country.
They weren’t buildings, exactly.
They were only buildings at a superficial
level.
First of all they had 5000 people in them,
or 5000 people died, if I remember correctly.
And then all those people were networked out
with all sorts of other people.
And they were networked at multiple levels.
So they were family members but they were
also elements of the financial and economic
machine.
And in the political machine.
And then what was hit was of course, not just
the buildings, but the economic and political
system, whatever that means.
And of course the people who took the towers
down weren’t trying to knock buildings down,
which is what you saw happen, they were trying
to knock down the things the buildings invisibly
related to.
And then you might ask well, what were those
buildings invisibly related to?
And it’s a simpler question to actually
reverse the question and ask, well what weren’t
they related to?
And the reason that people were traumatised
in the aftermath was because when we, when
our bodies, in some sense, answered that question,
the answer was, uh oh, those buildings were
probably attached to everything in every possible
way.
And so God only knows what’s going to come
leaping out of that.
So what happens when you see the buildings
fall, the facts that you see the buildings
fall actually blinds you to what’s happening.
It’s a very peripheral representation of
the actual event.
Because you could also say, well it was a
psychological event, you know, it echoed inside
of you.
Well, you don’t see that, you feel it, and
you don’t really know what it means.
But it puts a wave of uncertainty, a radical
wave of uncertainty, into everything.
And not only the present, but also the future
for sure.
Because things took a vicious turn after that,
and almost immediately, right?
The whole political system readjusted itself,
it became much more authoritarian.
You know, airports became little fascist enclaves.
You know for me, for many people, I could
hardly go into an airport.
It just drove me crazy to be lined up like
that and then subject to search, you know,
by faceless representations of the paranoid
state.
God, that’s a horrible thing to have to
encounter.
It’s a bloody horrible thing to train people
to get accustomed to.
It’s really dangerous to train people to
accept that sort of thing.
It was a way worse consequence I think, than
the buildings falling down themselves.
But that was one thing that happened.
What else happened?
Well the one trillion dollar surplus that
was projected by the Clintons at the end of
Bill Clinton’s presidency, which was the
prediction for the next ten years, that the
economy was doing so well that the US government
was going to have a one trillion surplus over
the next ten years, turned into a four trillion
dollar deficit.
So that happened.
Well and then we got tangled up even worse
in the Middle East, and of course that, I
think that’s probably got worse as time’s
gone on rather than better.
And we have no idea where that’s going to
end.
You know, I mean Russia’s involved now,
and Russia rattled nuclear weapons at Turkey
the other day.
You know, even though Turkey’s their largest
trading partner and a member of NATO.
And then you know, a million refugees flooded
into Europe, and God only knows what’s going
to happen as a consequence of that.
And it’s not like the people who planned
the bomb didn’t know that, like here’s
what they thought.
They thought “oh, the Soviet Union, that
was the second greatest power on Earth, and
then they waded into Afghanistan.
And they got tangled up in a terrorist war
and oh, poof!
Ten years later they didn’t exist.
Maybe we could do the same thing to the United
States”.
It’s like, well, who knows?
Maybe you could.
I mean they certainly…
the response to the 9/11 disaster, in my opinion,
was much more expensive than the disaster
itself.
I mean, one of the things that’s quite horrifying
is that here’s one statistic: nobody flew
in the aftermath of 9/11 for a while.
Like airplane flight bookings were way down.
More people died in car accidents (because
of not flying) than were killed in the bombings.
And no one ever noticed that, because people
are being killed on the highway all the time,
right?
I mean it’s background noise as far as we’re
concerned.
But you know, it’s a really good example
of how not only do you not know what the event
is, you can’t even tell who the event killed.
And so it’s your apprehension of that, when
it occurs, that paralyses you.
And so that’s the dragon of chaos, roughly
speaking.
That’s an unknown unknown.
It’s like all of reality, all of the multiple
levels of reality that exist around you are
all of a sudden altered in an incomprehensible
manner.
And then you could say that well, what happened
was the alteration of that reality.
This is what happened.
It’s that you can only perceive it, essentially,
as the explosion in the building and the consequent
collapse.
And so you might say that the Twin Towers
were brought down.
It’s like that’s such a low-resolution
representation of what happened that it barely
begins to describe that event.
And so it’s that invisible background of
complex interrelationships, like a very, very
complex melody, that’s always going on around
you.
And as long as it works you don’t even notice
it.
What happens is that it manifests itself as
predictable and desirable order.
Which you can understand, and which is the
reason we have predictable and desirable order.
This room is configured so that you can walk
into it without being afraid.
And what that means is that it’s a radically
simplified version of reality.
You know, and you can see that, I mean, it’s
even got padded walls, and that’s to stop
the sound bouncing so that it won’t annoy
you.
You know I mean it’s warm, it’s comfortable,
it’s sort of neutral so it fades into the
background.
Everyone here is civilised beyond belief.
You hear about the radical individualism of
the West…
I think of all the nonsense I’ve ever heard
that’s got to be the most nonsensical, we’re
so bloody obedient that it’s insane.
If you go to Edmonton at 3 o’clock in the
morning and watch pedestrians, they will stop
at the ‘don’t walk’ light and wait until
it turns green [laughter].
Now the roads are wide and so they… but
it’s still the case.
It’s like, really??
You think you’re an individual, really?
And I’m not complaining about it, I think
it’s an amazing thing because you know we
can really zip cars through our cities because
people don’t run out into the middle of
the streets and get killed, they stay where
they’re supposed to so it’s incredibly
efficient.
But we’re so obedient and well-behaved that
it’s beyond… if you think about us as
chimpanzees with clothes, you know, we’re
doing pretty damn well.
And we set up our environments so that they’re
so simplified that we never have to encounter
this multi-dimensional layered reality of
patterns that’s just moving around us all
the time and that actually makes up reality.
That’s reality, that’s what the world
is made out of.
That’s a way different way of thinking about
it than to think of the world as made up of,
say, of atoms.
Because you think, that way you just think,
well it’s marbles in space, you know.
And of course atoms aren’t marbles, and
everyone knows that, like God only knows what
they are.
But that’s still the image, that’s still
the metaphor, of reality.
But that’s not what reality is.
It’s an insanely patterned orchestra of
phenomena and that’s really what it is and
then what happens is that you’re in this
little orderly sub-compartment in the middle.
It’s like, you’re in a box and the box
is in a box.
Well, let’s think about it.
You’re in a box, okay, this box is in a
building, that’s a box.
The building is in the university, that’s
a box.
The university is in the city, that’s a
box.
The city is in the province, that’s a box.
Then it’s in Canada, then it’s covered
by the American nuclear umbrella, you know,
and then it’s embedded in this immense history
of individual rights and freedoms that have
manifested themselves as part of the political
and economic order.
And all of that’s going on around you and
people are working like mad, crazily, to keep
all of those boxes intact, and here you are
sitting and thinking, well, what you see around
you is reality.
It’s like it is, yeah, but man, there’s
a lot of people making this reality so simple
that you don’t have to think about it.
You can come in here and think about ideas,
you know for like hours at a time, and you
don’t get eaten by a crocodile.
It’s really… and you know no one comes
running through here pillaging, which is of
course…
the crocodile eating and the pillaging were
very, very common occurrences in our evolutionary
history.
For lots of our ancestors going down to get
water from the local river was a life or death
mission.
I mean I can’t imagine having to get water
from a crocodile infested stream.
Especially when that’s where the lions are
hanging out too, you know.
So, that’s order.
That’s the positive element of order.
Now you can say, students say this a lot:
“oh my God, I’m so constrained within
these boxes, it’s destroying my individuality”
you know.
And that’s the tyrannical…
I mean it’s pathetic in some sense, because
God, you’re so privileged it’s beyond
comprehension.
But having said that, it is also the case,
and the case has to be made, that you do have
to sacrifice your potential to cultural norms.
And that is… you can argue that that’s
destructive.
And sometimes it is destructive.
Like creative people don’t fit very well
into nested boxes.
And in order for them to fit they have to
do damage in some sense to their psyches,
because they’re not naturally made to…
that isn’t their natural environment, boxes
within boxes.
And so they might say, well I’m being oppressed.
It’s like, well of course you’re being
oppressed.
If you’re in fifty boxes that’s constrain
your freedom of movement, but maybe you should
be somewhat grateful for the fact that the
boxes exist.
You think, well you don’t even notice them.
The boxes are so effective that you don’t
even notice them.
You can even criticise them, and you should,
you know, maybe they could be better and not
quite as rigid, and so forth.
And the criticism is justified but you have
to keep both of the representations in mind
at the same time, you know.
Your culture is the wise king and the despot
at the same time.
And people hate that sort of thing because…
and you know our rational minds and our history
of logical intellectual thinking has forced
us to assume that a thing can’t be itself
and its opposite at the same time.
But unfortunately when you’re talking about
very large-scale categories, things are what
they are and their opposite at the same time.
Because culture is the wise king and the tyrant,
and that means it’s very difficult to adjust
your behaviour in relationship to it, because
you never know if you’re talking to the
wise king or the tyrant.
You know, and you feel that.
If you have to do your taxes or if you have
to deal with the university bureaucracy in
some way, it’s like, you’re a number,
you know, and you’re just annoying, like
patients in the hospital, because hospitals
would run a lot better if they didn’t have
any patients in them, obviously.
And you know, you feel that, of course, whenever
you’re in a very complex bureaucracy.
It’s like, you’re exchangeable, and that’s
very annoying.
But by the same token, here you are.
So you have to criticise… this is also a
very complex form of moral behaviour.
You have to criticise with gratitude.
And that’s something that students should
really be taught in university, because the
opposite of gratitude is resentment, and there
is nothing that’s more pathological than
resentment.
The only thing that comes close to resentment,
in terms of its capacity to produce misery,
is arrogance, and those things are often…
arrogance, resentment, and deceit… it’s
like that’s the evil triad.
You get all those three things going in your
life and boy, you’re going to be in rough
shape very, very rapidly.
So then, let’s take a break, for fifteen
minutes, okay?